fired Trump a timer roasted today
released yet another audio recording she
secretly recorded this time featuring
Trump campaign staffer his Lynn Patton
and Katrina Pierson discussing a rumor
that President Trump was caught on tape
using the n-word president Trump Viet
Minh Lee denies that he's been ever
caught on tape using a racial slur
joining me now for reaction is the one
of the people you heard on that
recording Lynn Patton currently a senior
adviser to Housing and Urban Development
Secretary ben Carson there it is great
to see you Lynn thank you so much for
joining us it's usually tonight great to
be here Laura
well tell us about that conversation
that took place the recording we just
heard it was just a part of a recording
from October of 2016 sure morosa you and
Katrina Pierson of course and first I
want to start off by saying thank you so
much for retweeting my statement last
night you know I know it's been getting
picked apart today and that's really why
I'm here is because you know there's
something seriously wrong with society
when a woman can run around the White
House and surreptitiously record people
possibly in violation of his of her own
national security contract but yet
Katrina and I are the ones who have to
come on national television and explain
ourselves you know I've made it very
clear and I stand by my statement that I
released last night that you know the
audio tapes that she's released first of
all conflate two different conversations
one is with me Omarosa and Katrina the
other is also with me Omarosa Katrina
and Jason but the distinction is muddled
and you know what you're hearing really
in my opinion is not only verification
the president said very early on and
very sternly and immediately that he did
not use this derogatory term but you
know the more I hear this recording what
you're also hearing is a woman Omarosa
who outright interrupts me during this
this interview and says he said it
that's a lie and you know why would she
go work for him if that was the case
well was she interrupting you you think
at that point in the recording she knew
she was recording it and she wanted her
own little insurance policy she wanted
to get it on the record that oh no he
said it and they know you raise a good
point because even my boyfriend this
morning had said to me that you know the
reason why Alma Rosa kept bringing this
elusive n-word tape up is because she
used it as opportunity to
surreptitiously record me obviously
Katrina possibly other people this was
something you know Omarosa has been
obsessed with the n-word since 2004 when
on Oprah Winfrey she accused one of the
apprentice contestants of calling her
the n-word but you were a friend of hers
land and and you're a very
well-respected person within the
administration I heard that from a lot
of different people from a lot of
different parts of the government you're
extremely well respected so you said
last night that you never participated
in a conference call with Omarosa and
katrina and yet then we hear a recording
of you in a conference call without
Marisa I read that like yeah like a look
of gee I was like why do you want to did
you forget that I Laura what I said
expressly was that we refuted what
Omarosa had told Chuck Todd and Savannah
Guthrie which was that we participate in
a conference call that confirmed Frank
Luntz had heard Donald Trump say the
n-word
that never happened okay but what so you
didn't participate in calls but just not
a call no it was described by her we
never denied multiple calls about the
elusive n-word tape or apprentice tape
because all morosa
was obsessed with with this imaginary
and quite frankly fictitious figment of
her imagination which I now know to
believe but she was she was with
tracking down something that she created
Lin Lin what what kind of person is she
you were friends with her right yeah I
mean obviously she's known the president
for 15 years she was extremely loyal to
him up until the day she wasn't you know
the president obviously is extremely
loyal to people who are loyal to him he
gave her multiple multiple chances and
what's really sad here Laura is that the
president gave her an opportunity to
really help the african-american
community and instead she did the exact
opposite by blocking you know reputable
Republicans black Republicans and
influential members of the community to
advance her own standing to the
detriment of this White House this was
what she said today with Katy tour
responding to president basically saying
it's good that John Kelly fired her like
a dog let's watch the president called
you a dog this morning what's your
reaction I think that it just shows you
that if he would say that publicly what
else would he say about me privately he
has absolutely no respect for women for
african-americans as evidenced by him
instructing the chief of staff to lock
me for two hours in the Situation Room
to harass me to threaten me and say that
things could get very ugly for me and
that there would be damage to my
reputation but he was unfit to be in
this office and to serve as a president
you know your reaction 'ln well you know
as I was saying earlier the president
has called a lot of people dogs he's
called Mark Cuban a dog he's called
Robert Patterson a dog he's called Bill
Maher a dog he's called Mitt Romney a
dog I mean to me that's not something
that's either Rachel or you know
specific to Omarosa what he's doing is
fighting back against somebody who has
wronged him and he has every right to do
that by any means necessary you know
Omarosa is in what I consider a
purgatory neither the right or the left
wants to claim her and taking her now
Landon's lessons lawmen on door now roll
real quick do you know why she was fired
we're really why she was well you know
I'm reading just like everybody else
that it has to do with obviously grave
violations of while she riding around on
a vehicle a government vehicle well you
know I can actually verify that one time
she asked me if we were I was at with
her at the White House she said that she
had to go meet somebody at this
restaurant on 7th Street you know we
both live across the street from each
other and different on Pennsylvania
Avenue
we went via a White House car service to
this restaurant as soon as we walked in
she said Lynn don't turn around but has
the SUV left yet and I looked and I said
he was still sitting there and she said
they're on to me they're waiting to see
if I come out of this restaurant because
it was really only two blocks away from
her apartment and it occurred to me what
she was doing Here I am standing in the
foyer of this restaurant with Alma Rosa
trying to hide you know and I said and
the hostess is looking at us and I'm
mortified because I thought we were
actually meeting somebody there well so
she's her mmm oh all right Lana thank
you so much for joining us I just want
to say one last thing real quick the
American people are sick of hearing
about em Omarosa you said they're sick
of hearing about stormy Daniels and
they're sick of hearing about collusion
it's time we focus about on the things
that they really need our jobs economy
health care and infrastructure and
that's what my boss is doing and you
wouldn't you wouldn't work for a racist
president neither would any of the
people I'm you can't pay me
there's not enough money in the world
bingo
dan thanks thanks so much so much